you know people like whatever I wicks
I'm laying low it let's rock so we just
keep it all out of the show I don't want
to tell them anything I want to repeat I
tell you I won't go don't like the best
you
what sling and dick and giving out
fortune cookies [ __ ] uncle Joey
Wednesday night going deep tonight my
main man Lisa at we got it with stacked
up tonight go really clueless I got a
little [ __ ] like a like a stroke
handed that's how good that [ __ ] bong
it was tremendous night that I have the
church we're going deeper than deep
tonight we're gonna [ __ ] to the
hemisphere tonight somebody's going to
the hospital
don't go nowhere don't care what you're
watching this is better understand me
you never see somebody rattle the
[ __ ] cage run away cuz I don't wait
for the ambulance I jumped the fence
ain't playing a teenager I tried myself
you know I'm saying we just drive with
an ambulance drove off in the front you
don't know that we take your ID you got
kidnapped by Patty Hearst and this is
what happen to them saying but we're
back it's what is it it's uh October
12th a beautiful night to be alive you
got pudding you got everything that the
cars on
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] guy trouble
footage they know chocolate pudding yeah
what oh [ __ ]
stars of death over for the Al Capone
look it's Jesus oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
remember the star they saw they thought
it was Jesus not it was all these things
you know how we do it people
I don't care what you got to do but if
you're 18 under 18 hang up now
[ __ ] I want you your mom call me
tomorrow you will forms from the [ __ ]
mouth you should I don't need that
aggravation
only over 18 stay out here I don't care
if your spear your grandmother's valium
tonight's your lucky night you're the
same we're on fire tonight
act like Trump grab somebody's [ __ ]
monkey what do you care
what do you care it's [ __ ] truffles
Oh check it out BAM we're going deeper
Lee you're puking all over yourself
already what the [ __ ] 27:45 just kids
having problems or at each 7:45 he's
already having problems
and that's it in that sense I'm happy
you're here I miss you edit the Chicago
tonight
and the red ice tape with a special
Saturday night but we'll be at Zanies
Rosemont tomorrow at eight o'clock
Friday 7:30 and 9:30 and then with
taping 7:00 and 9:30 Saturday it's over
but the shouting I'm ready to go we did
the our run-through last night I worked
hard so I got no problems whatever how
come my heart and souls gonna be insane
and at the end of the day that's all
that matters the power of Christ compels
you what are you feeling
forget about it's like Jim Jones without
Guyana
you want me to say [ __ ] house what do
you want an APB bill ain't got time for
you people all right got time for you
people what I do have time for a couple
bong hits for Jerry's kids get the party
serratus everybody gets nice it loose
and I'm saying you gotta be loose like
Tony Montana 84 you gotta be looser good
time I got dirt
you say I deal with four years of
college four years the [ __ ] college
here we go Lisa he's about to see it for
you in the college look what happened to
college
what do you shave your sideburns wrong
oh my god you gotta get a [ __ ]
protractor
come in come in here we go what's the
problem we still got some mushrooms left
you see what happens when you don't go
to [ __ ] training camp you see what
happens we don't go to training
so that he takes the weekends off from
doing bong as I tell them stop that's
Monday what about Tuesday there's seven
days of the week you want to do training
like once a week again you can't show up
with the carriage once a week I'm saying
the other will deep until murky waters
of the underworld three four times a
week I think how you'll expand your
lungs how long we don't listen
I feel like Paulie in Goodfellas I tell
them they don't listen comes they will
show you sweat your blood pressure's up
it's down you took like a bangle and
drank like a Red Bull yeah
Leena do because I'm a training
[ __ ] when people are sleeping up
creep telling these people no it's a
vicious and that's it that's that but
here when were there when I do this show
we'll wait our guest right now the
beautiful mr. Bruce Buffer
bad [ __ ] he's probably on a
chariot on his way up here whipping a
horse or some [ __ ] yelling at people
what's the story Lee say raise another
bond are you gonna sit there [ __ ] you
might walk on one leg you know the funny
you can't walk on one leg that's it
that's all I'm trying to tell you people
it's not the perfume that you wear it's
not the ribbons in your hair
I'm ready for Chicago baby it's over
Landon come on I was doing the show beat
the Greek he's showing up
he's taking us for a nice [ __ ]
sandwich
I just want a sandwich I said I'm
content I'm gonna try to stick to the
pre-christmas [ __ ] diet this mutts
always about my shakes and fry ok chick
ain't get no cake [ __ ] we got a [ __ ]
cake Chaney only up 50 years old for the
cake shakes what's next the Hat with a
[ __ ] propeller on it yeah [ __ ] a cake
shake no they don't give you a location
don't think they give you a cake Jake is
a diabetes [ __ ] card you'll get
insulin
we're trying to do it right tonight it's
Wednesday night I haven't seen you for a
couple days you ready let's go no all
right I'll give you some green hey hey
there you go thank you get some green oh
say you got someone gets black yeah
that's why I call that's what the
problem isn't American who these guys
somebody gets black let's go cut a
second cut this [ __ ] let's do this one
time well this one time that's beautiful
training right there I'm talking to
these people I didn't ask you no
questions anyway listen to me we're
getting tuned up here we'll be back in
ten minutes what's the thing youtube.com
slash sleep slash Joey Diaz again for
you people in the cheap seats
youtube.com slash slash c / Joey this is
bothering you people we got to do a
couple buckets in the other we are the
few edibles we drank some water
what are you we're gonna get that type
at the table you sit now i Netflix
trying to find out what to do with your
life maybe I don't know what to do
there you go I'll catch you guys in ten
minutes they black uncle Joey loves you